good morning John so in my last video I
was to make a video about the James Webb
Space Telescope and then the nerdiest of
the Nerds and the comments were all so
today I must talk about the James Webb
Space Telescope because it's awesome but
by way of a longer and second
introduction to this topic I have a
thing to say I personally believe that
there are two ways to make the world a
better place you can decrease the suck
and you can increase the awesome now
these are not mutually exclusive things
that's hard to say mutually exclusive
but they're also not the same thing and
it's clear that decreasing suck is
extremely important probably in the end
more important than increasing awesome
and that's when I talk about the space
program people are always like NASA's
money could be better spent on services
for Humanity and to them I say I do not
want to live in a world where we only
focus on suck and never think about
awesome if we lived in that world then
people would play soccer by having both
teams stand and guard their own goal the
whole game with the ball sitting at
midfield and then at the end of the game
we're supposed to all celebrate cuz no
one scored any goals against our team
that's not gonna get you on SportsCenter
we have to guard the goal and we have to
try and prevent bad things from
happening but we also have to make good
things happen and that is why I love the
James Webb Space Telescope
it's the Space Telescope version of a
freaking awesome
frickin Space Telescope this thing gives
me serious nerd woods
so without further ado my nerdy comrades
here the top 5 reasons why the James
Webb Space Telescope freakin kicks ass
it is huge
the total mirror size is seven and a
half times larger than the Hubble Space
Telescope's meter the heat shield is the
size of a tennis court number four it's
a freakin transformer because it's so
huge it could never fit in its full form
in the top of a rocket ship and so in
order to fit into the rocket it's
SuperDuper folded up and then when it
arrives it unfolds in like 12,000
different marvelous little ways that
could go wrong at any moment and it
freaks me out because I worried about
that and oh woe for Humanity no one is
going to be there to see this thing open
up but luckily the wonderful computer
animators at NASA have given us the
images that I have been showing you
number three it will operate 1 million
miles from Earth
it's about four times as far away from
the earth as the moon is the Webb
telescope actually orbits the Sun that's
a simplification that's actually in the
relative stationary Sun earth Lagrange
point to which I'm not going to try to
explain to you right now if it screws up
there's no way to fix it you may have
noticed that we went to fix the Hubble
like ten thousand different times well
we're not gonna get that opportunity
with the James Webb Space Telescope one
off one chance to do it right or it's a
six billion dollar piece of space junk
that is tense
number two it will be able to see
planets orbiting stars in our galaxy
individual planets if the James Webb
Space Telescope was 25 light years away
it could see the earth it can also
determine the chemical composition of
planets and it can peer into stellar
nurseries to see planets as they form
watch solar systems forming and finally
the James Webb Space Telescope can see
thirteen point four billion years into
the past
this is particularly impressive because
the universe is 13.7 billion years old
we will be seeing the first galaxies as
they form the first stars as they form
and guess what none of this is necessary
to life on earth none of its going to
help us cure malaria or install a
democracy in Egypt but it is awesome in
the truest sense of the word awesome I'm
sorry that there's so many hand gestures
in this video I'm feeling very gesturing
this is the dawn of everything that we
know and that is increasing awesome and
that is something that I can get behind
John I'll see you on Friday